you want to know something crazy
you know how we just came back from La
yesterday right to go see um taika's new
neurologist is that water on the lens
okay much better
well guess what
I'm going back to LA
today tonight to be exact
and under most normal circumstances yeah
we're pretty busy and we try to stay
together but we also try to be efficient
so usually
um Jill and tiger would have just came
back and I would just stayed in LA
because I have to shoot all my JK stuff
but
we're running really low on our podcast
stockpile so for us to be efficient what
we usually try to do is shoot like three
or four of them in a day so we had to
come back because the podcast studio is
here
so I'm going to shoot all of that and
then jump on a flight and get back to LA
the problem is
I decided or we decided to for me to fly
yesterday so I haven't even booked my
flight yet
and I have no idea if there's going to
be flights available but it has to be a
flight because on Saturday Geo's brother
and Titus cousins are coming up to visit
so I'm gonna cut JK news short half day
and I'm coming back to Vegas and if I
drive I'm gonna put an additional four
or five hours on the road so I ended up
coming here in the afternoon rather
during noon time so it wastes their time
so yeah lots of
back and forth LA to Vegas this month is
not as crazy as last last month
emotionally for sure but logistically
it's pretty nuts trying to get uh
taika's doctor stuff settled
to prep for the shoot
I don't like to think about food
mid-shoot because it ruins the momentum
like you ever like eat something you're
like oh I'm so tired now I'm slow and I
can't think well that's what happens
when it comes to filming so I'm trying
to pre-eat some food so we could just
bang out three or four episodes right
away so I got my little coffee
ready got a little peanut butter jelly
sandwich well with CUNY is um that's
actually pretty low calorie because when
we're getting ready for taika to go on
keto we bought keto stuff and I saw how
low calories it is because it's like
lacks a bunch of sugar I got it from
Trader Joe's like this one is a unsalted
peanut butter from Trader Joe's
and then there's a like no sugar
added a reduced sugar strawberry
preserves so I can actually fit more of
the yummy food that I want with some of
his keto stuff
um so that's been helpful because then I
don't feel like I'm on such a
restrictive diet and I think
I still look decent for someone that's
not tracking as hard as I was on get
lean I think I still
look decent look let's see
[Music]
I can't tell in this mirror but not bad
right
nah should I do look a little bit
fluffier but anyway that's not the point
the point is I found some low calorie
options for a peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches
so since we filmed the podcast in our
office now
it's kind of a blessing and a curse
it's a blessing because I actually
really like this studio better than the
last one let me know in the comments
below if you guys agree the other one I
think we really wanted to just try
making like a professional studio in our
house
because we've never done that before
which is why like we black out the
window so we pretty much made it a Sound
Stage we hung permanent lights down from
the ceiling we got super expensive
lighting
the problem is I think with how
vulnerable and how raw our conversations
are
it didn't feel like the studio matched
the tone of the conversation like in uh
filmmaking or production in general your
goal is you want to support the content
everything is to support the content
right like even the cast The the
Wardrobe the locations like everything
is to support the content and we thought
it was getting pulled in two directions
like one of us super polished
professional looking but then we're raw
and we're just going bananas so what I
really like about our office is it feels
raw like this is our actual workspace
kind of like JK news right like I think
maybe that's why I feel so real like
we're actually filming where we're
working the problem is sometimes it's a
big old mess
so in addition to having to set up all
the lights and equipment and stuff I
still have to
clean it up before we shoot and I hate
getting into logistical things before I
shoot because it kind of ruins
creativity but you gotta do what you
gotta do and under most circumstances I
probably would have cleaned last night
because I hate doing things last minute
but as you guys know I'm taking Titus to
the doctor in La yesterday so
I told you I can clean up your site I
don't know what the hell to do so I
gotta clean up this side um hopefully I
can get it done like 20 minutes maybe
and set up lights 30 minutes total
bam just like that like a NASCAR pit
Champion got everything set up got the
mics put in
got the lovely cast in place I also was
like the pit crew and got like
I did some hard work did you see what I
looked like before wow yeah you look
like a Ferrari I hope so I mean I tried
really hard
like really really hard I also like that
you only just focused on yourself
and look at me still and I focus on us
give me a pound back please
on the back please no you're talking
you're talking I'm just kidding so I got
everything set up got her close up
the wide the close-up
quick and nasty light real quick
and let me show you let me show you this
beautiful models look at that
is that freaking good
or what you see that
I'm talking about look at that
look at that I'm sorry
look at this pull Focus real quick look
at that and yes there's a little ghetto
piece of art because the light goes
crazy but as you can tell it looks kind
of weird in the white right but in the
close-up can't even tell what it is
on this camera because this Show's real
life but on the studio camera you can't
even tell and on this dude
and yeah on this camera right here and
on this the actual wide you can't even
tell because because I'm an artiste I
framed it where I chop off the top so
you don't know what goes beyond the
frame so it looks like that frame is
just hung on the wall you know what I'm
saying because I'm a straight up like
people some people call me Van Gogh but
I wouldn't dare to go that far but
that's what they call me see see how I
chopped it up start cutting some [ __ ]
off see how I chopped it off right there
oh that's what you chopped though can't
even tell
what what did you chop off his ear
his nose
what do you chop up do you even know
before you make fun of me I do know what
what am I gonna tell you what what what
what what what what what what what
can you just hurry I'm like barely
holding it hey all right this is the
part that I hit the most
took a shower
because it was warm now I can't move
because the minute I start moving I
start sweating oh God I know it sucks so
what I can do now is pop the cards in
still and still keep things moving
forward and this is how I keep my card
stuff organized you see I have like
podcast empty podcast full Vlog empty
Vlog pool because they all share the
same cards
and I don't want to get things mixed up
you know because I got a lot of stuff
going on and since I don't have a team
over here over here it's just myself I
got to manage all these cameras try to
be as organized as possible
and did you guys see my Ninja Turtle
office poster
okay so now it's intense time we just
wrapped up
um shooting podcasts uh we took tiger
digits
papa is supposed to fly out to
California today lucky for us his flight
got canceled maybe not so lucky for him
what did I say got canceled delayed
sorry uh but now it's rush hour for Papa
because not the movie
but real Russia yeah like he really has
to rush now he like just uploaded some
footage or I think it's still uploading
as we speak he hasn't even packed it and
your flight leaves at what time so I
need to leave in like 30 minutes hey
that's not bad what else you got to do I
haven't even packed it so I got a pack
[Music]
oh I think you got the attention
are you done eating no but you're not
done eating true
you got the attention of someone okay
we're gonna finish eating and then what
I got it but look you have to go he has
to go he has to go let's go let's go
but I do want to show off my closet can
I just show off my side of my closet I
started cleaning it and I'm almost I'm
almost done
Papa do it look I'm almost done look at
that
not where it wanted to be yet but I'm
almost done
I'm in a rush
and never get over this View
So Dope into all the houses
pocket you missed it
thank you
all right so the whole gang is here to
see me off which is so CUNY we got a
little taika and his nogi Jiu Jitsu
outfit and a robe I got Mama right there
I got my other Mama wonderful wife right
here everyone's so Kitty but I'm in a
big rush everyone to say bye so goodbye
what
so I was able to make it through TSA in
one piece
one thing did happen today that has
never happened to me before
um I've never seen them closed at TSA
pre-check line
but they did and I always have TSA Pre
and if any of you guys travel a lot
domestically I highly recommend getting
TSA pre-check because it can save you a
good 30 minutes sometimes like the
regular lines could be really long but
TSA Pre it moves faster you don't have
to take your laptop out you know take
off her shoes and all that and then if
you're traveling nationally make sure
you get either Global Entry or you get
clear then you can go through even
faster but they shut down the TSA
pre-check line so I have to go through
the regular line
and then in that regular line it took a
minute so I kept looking at my watching
am I going to make this flight because
everything is down to the last second I
made
one
emotional decision and it wasn't that
smart so when we're done with the
podcast I looked at the time and I had
perfectly had enough time to organize
the footage
send it
and then wrap up a couple of bottle
Brigade things that I still have to do
because we have a launch coming out
and then pack
and then that would have gave me like a
one hour buffer and I could take my time
to get dinner and all that before I get
on my flight
but I in my heart I really wanted to go
to attack us Jiu Jitsu and just all the
stuff that he's going through like he
doesn't really have school right now
he's missed a couple of basketball
practices and I just know how much like
group extracurricular activities mean to
him
so I was like I really want to go but I
know it's going to throw me off because
I have to drive 20 minutes to a sujitsu
drive 20 minutes back to the throne it's
a whole hour and the attacker comes up
to me he goes Papa
are you gonna watch my Jiu Jitsu today
and I was like
of course
so I went it was worth it
everything ended up working out at the
end we had a good time watching them in
jiu jitsu
and actually even
we today's no key day and we actually
put a key on them so I have to buy my
brand new ghee but what's CUNY is like a
bright red one so that uh
made me really really happy let me show
you what this fool looks like during
class it's just freaking hilarious okay
so check this out in his bright red rash
guard
this is how this guy pays attention
and or lacks of paying attention in
class
which is ridiculous and I don't know why
my phone is acting weird let me see all
right
look at this dude you see him right
there laying down
staring at the coach it is bright right
why is he the only student laying like
that
this guy is such my son I love him so
much
do I was pretty scared that they were
gonna delay my flight because my flight
was already delayed one time today my
flight was actually supposed to be at
five and they pushed it back so when
that alarm went off I was like oh [ __ ]
are they gonna cancel this flight am I
did I waste all that time did I have to
go home and get back in the car and then
drive to La you know and then get to La
by like midnight and just waste like a
whole six seven hours but thank God I'm
boarded on the plane now going to La so
that was a crazy false alarm
dude last night until this morning has
been a blur I'm at JK now but as soon as
I got home I [ __ ] crashed because
there was like some sort of luggage
problem at the airport for some reason
so everyone was standing around for an
hour so I thought I was going to be home
by 10 I ended up being home like 11 30
going to sleep at 12. the problem is I
gotta wake up and train the next day at
um
at six right so I woke up this morning I
was like [ __ ] I don't even want to train
so I'm so [ __ ] tired and [ __ ] but I'm
glad I went because I gotta share some
stuff with y'all check it out
hit some pretty heavy sets of deadlifts
check it out five plate for four boom
boom
boom
boom look at that for one set
two sets three sets yeah that sounds
great to help me
so yeah that was definitely a volume PR
volume PR meaning like how many total
reps and sets I did so three by four
that's 12 reps of 4.95 in one session
that was pretty damn dope and then after
that I hit another uh big PR because you
know like when you squat look it's a
dude
hey what are you filming over here dude
dude nothing man just conspiracies
I saw that that was pretty fast it's
gonna be a blur on your camera
I don't know if you have the FX to fix
that but the FX yeah that's what they
call it in the industry yeah no just F
and X I gotta I gotta be on time yeah
because my boss I was already on time
bro
I'll see you I'll see you inside I'll
see you get out of here
yeah but I had another PR which I was
really really happy with
um so usually when you hit squats first
oh yeah it's easier when you're trying
to squat after your deadlift your dads
are [ __ ] dead but check this out
I was able to hit five plates
my little war cry Chappelle what's up
dude
look at this point let's check it out
4.95
yeah you could park right there
bam look at that
oh damn five plates
after death
hey
you know some people call me OG some
people call me has been I think I'm
still hitting my Prime man now it's time
to get into JK
welcome back dude what's so funny dude
every camera
this makes cameras look small yeah
that's like a giant [ __ ] camera but
for for me but that looks like a [ __ ]
cell phone for you dude how big you look
behind the camera I can't see it he
called me buff you got nah
who do you think is buff
[ __ ] old Ronnie Coleman dude he looks
like a he's a freak dude that's
different
I think your standards are all [ __ ]
no I think I'm in the middle part has
body dysmorphia I think I'm in the
middle do you think Bart has bodies are
you in the middle yes on [ __ ]
toothpick Island yeah dude so so I think
I think in Fitness if you're 200 pounds
that's a fitness medium damn damn I'm
really under average in the fitness game
but in regular that is not normal I
think regular it's like what 170 or 160s
in the middle I'm an artist your scale's
[ __ ] up I'm like a thread
you know somebody mistaken me for Russ
swole the other day isn't that crazy no
you don't think that's true that's
impossible I don't think that's right
the skin color is way off yeah they they
sign me from behind and they're like oh
they thought I was wrestling oh they saw
your back yeah
everybody keeps tagging you out dude I
feel I'm like damn dude I guess I'm ugly
that guy still needs his mom to uh he is
kind of ugly
he still needs his mom to take him to
practice
little better looking than that dude
because he's so young he's a senior in
high school in the UFC isn't that crazy
yeah
yeah this is cauliflower you don't you
know J.R De Guzman so I was hanging out
with him this weekend why are you just
[ __ ] name dropping like that yeah
because bro I gotta like that anyway but
he was telling me that people send Raul
Rosas Jr to him and they say that he
looks like him he does like kind of look
like him in the eyes but Guzman is too
handsome Guzman is really handsome what
about have you said about me dude I'm
saying that you're not as handsome as
Guzman yeah that's true that's true do
you guys do pre-workout yeah I do what
is this you're [ __ ] liver King
steroids ah dude this is this is my
twelve thousand dollar stack a month
it's not really working oh [ __ ] you okay
oh my God you're just crash into the
sign
depending on who is this hey dude
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that's so what the [ __ ] do you have in
here it's protein dude no for us protein
yeah it's protein I got protein here too
all right how come you don't drink
we got special naps over here it's like
a clear one yeah oh you got ice up here
yeah oh okay I bought the wrong flavor
and I bought five tubs of it and I hate
five tubs why'd you buy can you return
it what flavor is it it's like it's like
cooler blue or something the ones in the
glass bottles yeah they don't taste as
good like the green apples
Amazon I know that's so [ __ ] up that's
so [ __ ] up because honestly like uh
I had a super hilarious day at JK news
we had Chappelle on and then we had
Jesus to pull it on crazy funny I
haven't died laughing in such a long
time now it's the end of the day been
chilling and then I've been catching up
with Joe Joe's been crushing it with his
jumbee and Waikiki how's it been over
there it's been [ __ ] Wild Man and by
the way if you guys are watching and you
stopped by to say what's up thank you
very much for coming through I love the
support that we've been getting
um what I noticed was that during
lockdown right yeah we still were
producing videos so I saw all the
numbers behind the screen but I haven't
seen the people face to face in a long
time because we haven't done a meet and
greet in ages and years yeah so then
like
we have at least like 40 of our
customers are fans whether it's local
folks from the island yeah or it's just
like people visiting and what makes me
feel like oh [ __ ] you guys are hella
[ __ ] down is that if I was out on a
vacation right like you're out there
watching whales like you're out there
sailing you're doing all this [ __ ] but
you you make it a point to come visit us
I think that's [ __ ] so cool and I
really feel like oh well I feel special
thank you guys yeah that's dope so yeah
if you guys are in Hawaii go visit
Junior over there they got custom unique
drinks too that you can't get on the
mainland so make sure you go check that
out now I'm gonna go hang and chill with
Joe because I only see them like once
every two weeks sometimes once every
month because I've been busy too and
I'll catch up with you guys later